Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Zilli Lee
J'ai une question pour vous.
J'aimerais savoir qui, dans la
salle, a déjà pris des congés payés.
Et si vous avez déjà pris des congés
payés, j'aimerais que vous vous leviez.
Est-ce qu'il y en a parmi vous ?
(Brouhaha de gens qui se lèvent)
Si vous pouviez rester debout quelques
instants, j'ai une autre question.
Est-ce qu'il y en a parmi
ceux qui sont encore assis
qui ont déjà utilisé un
moyen de contraception,
homme ou femme ?
Si vous pouviez vous lever également.
(Rires)
J'en vois qui sont encore assis.
Est-ce qu'il y en a parmi ceux-là
qui ont déjà lu un magazine indépendant,
comme Fakir, par exemple ?
Alors là, je pense que j'ai
quasiment tout le monde debout.
Merci, vous pouvez vous rasseoir.
Si vous et moi étions debout ce soir,
c'est parce qu'une chose nous relie :
c'est l'engagement.
Il y a des hommes et des femmes
qui, un jour, se sont engagés.
Ils se sont battus.
Et aujourd'hui, ces droits
sont normaux, on les a acquis,
et ça nous paraît normal,
mais ça ne l'était pas auparavant.
Et si je suis là, c'est pour vous parler
de comment, malgré moi,
je suis tombée dans
cette marmite de l'engagement,
et comment, de l'engagement,
j'ai glissé vers la désobéissance civile.
(Rires)
Un grand programme. (Rires)
Je ne viens pas d'une famille
militante, encore moins activiste.
Mon éducation politique s'est résumée
à une explication vague
sur la différence entre la droite
et la gauche quand j'avais 15 ans.
Un peu flou !
Mais toujours est-il que ma mère,
dès que quelqu'un accusait
une autre personne d'un acte commis,
elle avait le réflexe de comprendre
ce qu'il y avait en-dessous,
de se poser la question :
quels arguments, quelles opinions,
quels points de vue il y a,
pourquoi cette personne est accusée de ça,
est-ce que vraiment
cette accusation est juste ?
Et elle avait toujours ce sentiment
de justice et d'équité
qui transpirait dans ses paroles,
ce qui m'a profondément marquée.
Et du côté de mon père,
c'était différent, il a passé
son enfance en Afrique.
Donc lui, il me parlait de cette Afrique,
de grands arbres, de singes,
de baobabs, de boas constrictors.
Et ce mélange, ces influences ont fait
que quand je me suis
retrouvée à 16, 17, 18 ans,
j'avais une envie de protéger la planète.
J'avais envie de travailler
pour protéger l'environnement.
Je ne savais pas vraiment
ce que ça voulait dire,
mais j'avais envie d'aller vers ça.
Et comme je ne savais pas faire
grand-chose, si ce n'est étudier,
je me suis dit : « Je vais utiliser
ce que je sais faire : les études. »
Et j'ai donc décidé de
devenir ingénieur forestier.
Et je suis devenue ingénieur forestier,
spécialisée en tropical,
puisque c'est là qu'il y a des
taux de déforestation alarmants,
et donc là où il y avait urgence d'agir.
Sauf qu'avant même de terminer mes études,
j'ai croisé la route d'une
femme absolument extraordinaire
qui s'appelle Claire Nouvian,
qui est une femme
qui a créé l'association « Bloom »,
une toute petite association
tout aussi extraordinaire,
qui se bat pour la
préservation des océans,
les océans et les océans profonds.
Et Claire Nouvian, pendant que
j'étais sur les bancs de l'école,
est venue et nous a parlé
pendant trois ou quatre heures,
de la destruction des océans,
de la dévastation de la
ressource marine par l'homme,
et de l'état catastrophique
de la ressource marine.
J'étais focalisée sur mes forêts et
elle m'a ouvert les yeux sur les océans.
J'ai fait : « Ouah ! Là aussi,
il y a quelque chose à faire. »
Sauf que je n'y connaissais rien,
donc j'ai terminé mes études.
Je suis partie dans le tropical, etc.
Et puis un an après, je reviens,
et j'avais toujours
cette association en tête.
Je me suis dit :
« Vraiment, j'ai envie de les aider. »
Je n'ai pas l'argent pour les aider,
pas la compétence océans,
encore moins le lobbying politique,
puisqu'elle travaille beaucoup
au Parlement, à Bruxelles.
J'ai regardé ce que je
savais faire, je me suis dit :
« Ça fait quelques années
que je fais de la vidéo,
pour communiquer sur les forêts,
et en vidéo, ils n'ont pas
grand-chose sur leur site Internet.
Peut-être que je peux
leur proposer de faire un film. »
J'ai envoyé un mail : « Bonjour,
on s'est rencontrées il y a un an.
J'aimerais réaliser un
documentaire sur votre combat,
avant de retourner dans mes forêts. »
Elles ont dit : « OK. »
et l'aventure a commencé.
Huit mois après, nous avons
publié un film, « Intox »,
en libre accès sur YouTube,
et il a plutôt bien fonctionné,
puisque quelques mois plus
tard, il faisait 30-35 000 vues.
Il fait 40 minutes.
Il a dépassé les 35 000 vues.
Il a été sélectionné
dans plusieurs festivals,
primé à un festival,
et il a terminé, notamment, en
projection-débat à l'Assemblée nationale
pour un débat sur la
pêche en eaux profondes.
Ça a été une aventure extraordinaire
car après, des gens sont venus
et m'ont dit :
« C'est toi qui as fait Intox ?
Écoute, depuis que j'ai vu ton film,
je donne à l'association Bloom »,
ou alors : « J'ai vu ton film
sur les poissons profonds.
Je ne peux plus manger de poissons
profonds, j'ai changé ma consommation. »
C'était très fort,
parce que moi qui n'avais pas de
compétences océan, politique, ou vidéos,
j'ai réussi à apporter
cette pierre-là à l'association.
L'aventure ne s'est pas terminée là :
on s'est tellement bien entendus,
que l'association Bloom m'a embauchée.
Je me suis retrouvée à travailler à Paris,
du jour au lendemain, sur les océans.
J'ai laissé les forêts.
On a travaillé ensemble sur les requins,
la préservation des espèces marines,
le lobbying.
Et puis la COP21 est arrivée.
Et pendant la COP21,
j'ai travaillé pour Bloom,
avec d'autres organisations,
et avec d'autres réseaux militants,
sur mon temps personnel,
sur la question du climat.
J'avais envie d'aller toujours plus loin,
sur plus de terrain, plus de créativité.
J'avais envie d'explorer ce monde-là,
militant, qui est passionnant.
Et là, j'ai reçu un mail.
J'ai reçu un mail d'une organisation
qui s'appelle « 350.org »,
qui m'invitait à participer
à une formation
pour être moi-même formatrice
pour les Climate Games.
Les Climate Games, c'est
un concept absolument génial
de désobéissance civile.
C'est un jeu grandeur nature qui
s'est déroulé pendant la COP21 à Paris,
et qui invitait les gens,
militants ou non,
à monter des équipes pour lancer
des actions directes et créatives,
ou des actions de désobéissance civile.
Ça pouvait être confrontatif,
comme aller bloquer
une entreprise pétrolière, par exemple,
le siège de cette entreprise à Paris,
mais ça pouvait être
des choses plus ludiques,
comme recouvrir la statue du lion,
Place Denfert-Rochereau, au sud de Paris,
en ours polaire.
(Rires)
C'était une action ludique, créative,
pour sensibiliser à la question du climat.
Voilà, j'ai sauté dans ce milieu militant.
Et puis, la COP21 s'est terminée.
Et on s'est retrouvés
avec tout un groupe de personnes;
formées comme moi pour être formateurs
et mobilisés aux Climate Games,
on s'est retrouvés et on s'est dit :
« L'accord de Paris n'a pas
encore réglé la question du climat.
Nous avons acquis des outils,
un réseau, nous avons des envies.
Est-ce qu'on ne pourrait pas continuer ? »
Et donc, nous avons lancé
le collectif « Diffraction ».
Ce n'est pas une association,
c'est un collectif informel.
Mais nous nous sommes
mis à nous voir régulièrement
et à lancer de nouveaux
ateliers et de nouvelles formations
pour aider ceux n'ayant jamais fait
d'action créative à en mettre en place,
à s'engager dans la désobéissance civile,
ou pour ceux habitués aux manifestations,
aux grèves très traditionnelles,
d'imaginer des moyens plus
ludiques, plus festifs et plus colorés,
pour changer un peu la façon
de s'engager dans la désobéissance civile.
Ça a bien fonctionné
pendant quelques mois,
et très vite, on a relié un mouvement
qui s'appelle « Break Free ».
C'est un mouvement de désobéissance,
mais au niveau mondial,
qui vise à laisser les
énergies fossiles dans le sol,
tout ce qui est charbon, pétrole, etc.
Il y a une action au cœur de ce mouvement
global, qui s'appelle « Ende Gelände »,
qui a eu lieu en Allemagne,
et qui visait à se rendre avec un
maximum de militants du monde entier,
sur une mine de charbon pour la bloquer.
Et ça a donné ça.
La première fois que les communautés
en Allemagne ont lancé ce mouvement,
ils étaient quelques centaines.
En 2015, ils étaient 1 500.
Et en 2016, nous étions 4 000
à bloquer les mines de charbon.
On s'est retrouvés
avec Diffraction et d'autres,
dont certains n'avaient jamais pris part à
une action militante, quelle qu'elle soit,
à bloquer des rails,
bloquer une centrale, et à la
faire fermer pendant plusieurs jours.
Tous les médias nationaux en ont parlé,
et ont parlé de la question du charbon
dans la crise climatique.
Et c'était très fort, et Ende
Gelände, en fait, c'était magique.
On avait tous des étoiles plein les yeux
quand on est revenus de ce mouvement,
car vous vous retrouvez avec des gens
que vous ne connaissez pas,
et vous vous rendez compte
que vous pouvez leur faire confiance.
Et ça, c'est incroyable, parce sur place,
vous vous retrouvez en train
de descendre dans la mine,
avec des gens comme vous, engagés.
Et vous savez ce qui se passe
en cas de garde à vue,
d'arrestation, de problème
de santé quelconque.
Il y a toujours un esprit
de bienveillance très fort,
et on ne se lance jamais tout seul.
On est toujours à 2, à 4, etc.,
on forme des groupes affinitaires,
on travaille ensemble pour être efficaces,
mais toujours dans un esprit durable,
dans un esprit de
bienveillance et de sécurité.
Et donc ça, c'est ce qui m'a beaucoup plu.
Sauf qu'en revenant d'Ende Gelände,
il y avait toujours cette crise climatique
pour laquelle nous étions en mouvement
et avions envie de nous battre,
mais il y a aussi la question
de l'urgence politique.
Et pendant la COP21,
ce qui m'a bouleversée,
c'est qu'après l'état d'urgence,
pendant que nous nous battions
pour les Climate Games, etc.,
il y a eu des assignations à résidence.
J'ai des amis, des collègues,
militants, écologistes,
qui se sont fait assigner à résidence -
avec impossibilité de se déplacer et de
militer pour la cause environnementale -
assignés à résidence
par notre propre gouvernement.
Et ça, ça m'a profondément choquée :
comment des militants écologistes qui
se battent pour défendre un bien commun,
une planète qui nous donne
des ressources qui sont à tous,
comment peuvent-ils se faire enfermer
ou supprimer leur liberté d'expression ?
Ça m'a profondément marquée.
Mais cet état d'urgence qui
est à la fois politique et climatique,
en face, il y a des gens qui s'engagent.
Et ça, c'est la bonne nouvelle.
Il y a des gens qui s'engagent
et ça fonctionne.
J'ai un exemple à vous donner,
en France dans les années 1990.
Je ne sais pas si vous avez entendu parler
du démantèlement du McDonald's de Millau.
C'est très simple : le préfet a donné
l'autorisation de construire un McDo.
Et les gens qui habitaient
là-bas ont dit :
« Vous savez quoi ? En fait,
on n'en veut pas, de votre McDo. »
Le gouvernement a quand
même donné les autorisations,
et le McDo a commencé à être construit.
Et plutôt que de se dire :
« Bon, c'est fait »,
ils ont dit : « En fait,
on n'en veut vraiment pas. »
Et ils se sont rassemblés,
des hommes, des femmes,
des jeunes, des moins jeunes,
avec José Bové, notamment,
ils y sont allés,
et ils ont pris les pièces du
McDo, et ils les ont démontées.
Et le McDo n'a jamais été construit.
C'est un exemple d'engagement frappant,
des hommes et des femmes qui ont dit :
« Ça, c'est légal.
Mais est-ce que c'est légitime ?
On ne pense pas. On n'en veut pas. »
Et ils ont agi.
Il y a un autre mouvement que j'aime
beaucoup, cette fois-ci aux États-Unis.
C'est un groupe de travailleurs agricoles,
un tout petit groupe
de producteurs de tomates,
qui avaient des conditions
de salaire absolument indécentes,
et des conditions de travail
indécentes également.
Ils faisaient des manifestations, des
grèves, et ça ne marchait pas ou très peu.
Un jour, ils se sont dit :
« Peut-être qu'on devrait s'associer. »
Ils se sont associés.
Et ils sont allés voir qui ? Ils sont
allés voir des étudiants, notamment.
Ils ont créé une alliance
avec les étudiants agricoles ,
et d'autres groupes, parfois religieux,
et d'autres groupes de travailleurs.
Et les étudiants ont
une force de frappe énorme.
Ils ont créé une vague
de mobilisation sans précédent.
Ils ont lancé des pétitions.
Et ils ont appelé au boycott.
Et ensemble, les ouvriers
agricoles et les étudiants,
plutôt que de s'adresser à leur employeur,
ils ont décidé de s'adresser
à ceux qui achetaient leurs tomates,
c'est-à-dire des entreprises
comme Taco Bell,
comme McDo, comme Subway,
c'est-à-dire des entreprises sur
lesquelles les citoyens pouvaient agir.
Et en lançant un appel au boycott,
et en lançant des pétitions,
les citoyens et consommateurs qui
ne connaissaient pas ce mouvement,
se sont engagés et ont boycotté Taco Bell.
Quelques mois après, Taco Bell signait
et augmentait les conditions
de salaire et de travail.
L'année suivante, McDonald's a signé
et l'année suivante, Subway,
jusqu'en 2014 où Walmart, une des plus
grosses multinationales agroalimentaires,
a signé un engagement.
Le plus beau dans l'histoire,
c'est que cette alliance continue.
Elle continue sur d'autres combats.
On va revenir en France.
Des exemples comme ça, dans le monde
entier, il y en a absolument partout.
Je vais juste revenir sur un :
la ZAD de Notre-Dame des Landes,
la Zone à Défendre.
Il y a quarante ans,
le gouvernement a décidé
qu'il voulait mettre un aéroport,
mettre du béton et des avions
sur des terres agricoles riches, fertiles,
riches en biodiversité notamment.
Les gens qui étaient là-bas - les années
ont passé, il y a eu tout un mouvement -
ont dit : « Vraiment,
on ne veut pas de cet aéroport. »
Et comme avec le McDo,
ils sont allés pour construire,
et eux, ils se sont mis
en travers en disant :
« En fait, vraiment, là, non merci.
Cette société-là, on n'en veut pas,
ni du béton et des avions.
On veut des terres agricoles, de la
biodiversité, des rivières, des bocages. »
Et aujourd'hui, l'aéroport,
il n'existe toujours pas.
Et si vous allez à la Zone à Défendre
de Notre-Dame des Landes,
c'est absolument magique,
une ambiance incroyable y règne.
Ce n'est pas un monde
de Bisounours, on est d'accord.
Il y a des tensions, c'est comme partout,
mais il y a des gens qui vivent
ensemble et testent des choses.
C'est un véritable laboratoire.
Et c'est une source
de créativité incroyable.
Vous avez des palissades
qui feraient pâlir d'envie
certains ingénieurs et architectes.
Il y a des cabanes dans
les arbres extraordinaires.
Et puis surtout, il y a une entente,
une coopération,
une bienveillance extrême.
J'y suis allée plusieurs
fois lors d'événements,
de rassemblements de plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de personnes.
Et vous pouvez vous balader, marcher,
aller chercher un truc à manger,
vous tombez sur des gens
qui vous parlent spontanément,
vous sourient, vous racontent
des histoires, vous racontent leur vie.
C'est une bienveillance qu'on retrouve
peu dans les grandes villes françaises
ou dans d'autres endroits du monde.
Cette bienveillance-là, c'est
ça que je recherche
dans le mouvement de l'engagement,
de la désobéissance civile.
Il y a beaucoup de combats à mener.
Et avant de vous laisser, j'aimerais
que vous vous posiez une question,
chacun d'entre vous,
que vous réfléchissiez
à la société que vous voudriez,
à la société que vous voulez maintenant,
que vous voulez demain,
au monde que vous voulez aujourd'hui,
puisque l'histoire de la société
est écrite par des hommes et des femmes.
Chaque homme, chaque femme l'écrit.
Ensemble, nous écrivons
l'histoire de notre société.
Et ensemble, nous changeons le monde.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)